[Music]  a positive mindset changes you  [Music]  which changes your ability to deal with  the shitty situation that you're in  i'm gonna put myself through this much  pain and suffering for a few seconds of  joy it's so [ __ ] worth it man it's  behavior first thoughts feelings and  perceptions  mental strength is much more powerful  than physical strength it's in that zone  that we have our greatest levels of  growth  and yes discomfort the discomfort is  again the price of admission to a  meaningful love  our minds are so powerful so even just  like changing the storyline makes it a  whole different game just try to find a  way to get one percent better each day  interrupting the patterns of thought  that are holding you back it is the only  way you are going to change mindset is  the single most important thing that  anyone can take out of this conversation  [Music]